my name is Jonathan sorry shout I think
my title should be former vice president
of the world bank and author well I was
lucky to be born in a very tiny country
my mother when she would go shopping
could be shopping in on single day in
Belgium for butter in Germany for
appliances in France for meat and in
Luxembourg for vegetables and so you had
a concept of a very small country that
didn't take itself too seriously in the
overall scheme of things moreover it's a
country that is straddling the German
culture and the French culture and so
when I went to school I had to learn to
read and write in German and then after
that the French would kick in and by the
time you were nine or ten years old it
was a sort of 5050 diet between French
and German in such a way that you would
have mathematics one year in German the
next year in French tanned in German
again and so forth so it was a very
multicultural upbringing and to make it
more complicated during the class breaks
we would speak yet a third language
which was the local dialect and so I
grew up in the place that is naturally
inclined to see the world as one big
place and it's a place where you don't
have strong nationalistic feelings in a
way and much of my thinking later has
something to do with that I had already
two doctorates when I decided to go to
the States I had a doctorate in
economics and one in law and so I did
the unusual thing of going to an MBA
program and not knowing much about that
world I picked the harvard business
school because it was the name that was
most familiar to me not knowing exactly
what I was getting into and so I started
in the u.s. not speaking very good
English and after six months at the
Harvard Business School I saw that was
the most
stupid kid and in the whole class
because it would take me forever to read
the cases at night but then it worked
out fine and I just loved that school
not that I learned much in the way of
academic content that I didn't know but
I went like all the other students
through hundreds and hundreds of case
studies of practical problem solving in
incorporations mostly and I learned to
work fast to cut corners to deal with
very complex documents and bring it down
to simple solutions and so forth so I
learned more in the in this first year
of the two-year program of the Harvard
Business School then I learned in many
years before and I sort of got quite
taken by the way of doing business that
characterizes the American system and
even to this day I live in Europe but
when I wrote my book I knew in about
which I'm sure will speak later I wrote
it in in English for the American market
in other terms today I'm so on both
sides of the Atlantic that I prefer
actually making speeches in in English
and my way of operating is more American
than in European but my deep roots are a
European
you